welcome back to our Fox News virtual
town hall with President Trump and
members of his coronavirus Task Force on
Bill Hemmer at the Rose Garden here at
the White House harris and i'm harris
faulkner in new york the
administration's 15 day plan you saw the
vice president holding that up several
times the plan is to curb the spread of
covin 19 in the united states and it's
set to expire in less than a week from
today now president Trump and his task
force are plotting the way forward for
all the nation in the next hour joining
us to talk about all that President
Trump and still with us vice president
Mike Pence the White House coronavirus
response coordinator dr. deborah birx
and the Surgeon General dr. Jerome Adams
and welcome and thank you all for being
here unusual circumstances where were
you're trying to communicate with the
American people we're trying to maybe
bring the American people a little
closer to you and get some answers to
you mr. president when was the moment
that you thought we got a move on this
well I think when I started seeing and
reading about China and seeing what was
going on in China Wuhan and specifically
it seemed to come mostly out of there
that area the province and when I saw
that and I saw the kind of death they
were you know talking about on
television on in the papers and I
started reading a lot about it and
really wanted had to make a decision do
I stop people from China and
specifically that area but from China to
come into the country and everybody was
against it almost everybody I would say
was just absolutely against it we've
never done it before we never made a
decision like did somebody come to you
with a bit of information and a piece of
data was it a world leader was it a
member of your own team no we had a
large group of people right behind me in
the Oval Office and I made it I
consulted with Mike but we made a
decision I made a decision to close off
to China that was weeks early and
honestly I took a lot of heat sleepy Joe
Biden said it's xenophobic I don't know
if he knows what that means but that's
okay he said it's racist what I did
thousands and thousands of more people
probably tens of thousands would be dead
right now if I didn't make that decision
and I must say doctors nobody wanted to
make that decision at the time it was
very very early called it lucky Cola
talent it doesn't matter we made a great
decision I took a lot of heat from China
they weren't happy with it now they
understand it and they've really you
know we're doing just fine but they were
not happy with it
bringing it it's not from a lot of
people bring the conversation to present
day and the past day and a half you got
a lot of tension for this a tweet that I
think went out late at night you said
the cure we cannot let the Cure be worse
than the problem itself so you start to
look at this 15-day period which will
come to us day 15 is next Monday today
arguably day nine what are you trying to
gauge as to how you can open the country
back up yeah when you say I took a lot
of heat for that essentially I really
didn't I mean a lot of people agree with
me our country is not supposed to be you
know it's not it's not built to shut
down our people are full of vim and
vigor and energy they don't want to be
locked into a house or an apartment or
some space they it's not for our country
if we're not we're not built that way
and I said you know I don't want the
Cure to be worse than the problem itself
the problem being obviously the problem
and you know you can destroy a country
this way by closing it down where it
literally goes from being the most
prosperous I mean we had the best
economy in the history of our country
three weeks ago and then all of a sudden
were supposed to shut it down and then
we're supposed to pay people not to go
to work we never had that we used to pay
people to go to work when I had but this
is a government order to go ahead and
stay home it's tricky though when you
try and turn the faucet back on New York
could be different from it is Utah
Louisiana could be different from
Arizona so how do you go about making
that decision well you have to make the
decision look we lose thousands I
brought some numbers here will as
thousands and thousands of people a year
to the flu we don't turn the country off
I mean every
year now when I heard the number you
know we average 37,000 people here can
you believe that and actually this year
were having a bad flu season but we lose
thousands of people a year to the flu we
never turned the country off we lose
much more than that to automobile
accidents we didn't call up the
automobile companies say stop making
cars we don't want any cars anymore we
have to get back to work now
with all of that being said it's
incredible what the American people have
done and and honestly the American
people have learned we've all learned
together between the shaking of the
hands and the washing of the hands
although I used to wash my hands that I
always wash my hands a lot I never was a
big believer in shaking hands once I
become a politician you shake hands and
you get a little bit used to it like
immediately when I see you I sort of
apologize that I'm not checking where we
exchange to air elbows which is seems to
be the thing is that I never like to see
that actually but but right now on
Capitol Hill you've got members of the
Senate debating a two trillion dollar
bill yeah more than did you think that
it it blows away the ability for us to
imagine that they could pass legislation
in excess of two trillion dollars now
who knows what's behind the curtain
there who knows what is stacked into two
trillion dollars how much concern do you
have well we can't deliver good she's
facing criticism that President Obama
faced and in 2009 we came out sweetheart
deals for certain companies as Democrats
would argue I cancelled the deal last
night I said I'm not gonna sign that
deal because Nancy Pelosi came in and
put a lot of things in the deal that had
nothing to do with the workers that had
to do with an agenda that they've been
trying to get passed for 10 years and I
came in I told Mike I told a lot of
people there's no way I'm signing that
deal I was getting calls from John
Kennedy from Ben Sasse from many many
people Lindsey I was getting calls from
a lot of different people saying this
deal Tom cotton to steel is terrible
what they've done they took a deal you
know we almost had a deal the day before
and it was between Schumer and
Mich and it was really a good solid you
all of a sudden they start throwing all
of the little green New Deal stuff in
right and the board rooms what they look
like and we want green energy we want
all this stuff let's stop drilling oil
they had things in there that were
terrible windmills all over the place
and all sorts of credits for windmills
they killed the birds and ruined the
real estate right a lot of problems I
mean a lot of problems and I said I'm
not signing this with two trillion
dollars now they've really hard to avoid
some of the holdout doors you could
argue but we have great things for not
only companies forget the companies the
companies are nothing other than they
are an employer of thousands and
thousands of people and they pay them
very well we want to protect our workers
I want to protect our workers workers
first mm-hmm but you have to protect
companies like Boeing they had a real
bad year let's face it with the problems
and they were in trouble before this and
then all of a sudden this happened we
can't lose a Boeing and we can't lose
some of these companies and companies
frankly bill that were solid as like
triple-a companies because of what's
happened over the last couple of weeks
they go from triple-a to being like they
could use a hand tough time we can't do
right we can't lose those companies if
we lose those companies we're talking
about hundreds of thousands of jobs
millions of jobs the faster we go back
the better it's going to be we have a
pent-up energy that's going to be
unbelievable gonna bring it back fast I
really believe I've got a lot more
questions and I might soon as my
colleague harris faulkner I'll allow her
to rejoin the conversation now Harris do
I have an ear plug here hello mr.
president so good to see you today this
will be a little bit to relay I
understand you guys are going back and
forth on the economy and employers but
more than 66 percent of people are
employed by small businesses the VP
talked a little bit about this we hear
you dropping big companies names the
question here is how do you shore up
both as you look forward the question is
a good one
and it's pointed you're talking about
Boeing and yet you've got what 2/3 of
American businesses or small business
and you think about what they're trying
to do in terms of adjusting to this new
reality has been thrown on them what
will you do for small business well
first of all I have to say that Harris
is one of my favorite people and I
didn't hear a word she said and I was
hoping it wasn't too devastating in
question but she is a fantastic person I
have to say that ok now that I've said
it because I can't hear Harris but know
the bill is very much focused on the
small business person it's very much
focused on small companies including
restaurants and all sorts of small
companies and what people don't realize
you know you're talking about these
massive we have the greatest companies
in the world you talk you add them all
up and the small businesses are just
about equal in size to these massive
companies of which we have many also
it's it's the engine of our country
small business this bill is absolutely
aimed at the small business and the
worker and the workers of those small
businesses and the owners the owners are
gonna need help they're gonna need some
loans they're gonna need things that
we're gonna be able to take care of them
because we don't want those small
businesses to go out of business nor do
we want the big businesses to go out of
business when they said mr. president we
gotta shut this down how hard did you
push back today I never heard of such a
thing we've had flus where we lose
36,000 we've lost as many I guess is
78,000 people in one year and they came
in and they said to be sure we're gonna
have to close the country I said what
are you talking about well we have a
virus it's coming in and I knew that and
I made the early decision with China so
I already already closed it off to China
and that was a long time before they
came in but they came in experts and
they said we're gonna have to close the
country I said we've never closed the
country before this never happened
before you're saying I said are you are
you serious about this we are going to
take this country that's fully employed
well we have 160 million people working
and you tell me we have to close it and
people are gonna go out of business and
they're gonna go bankrupt and they're
not gonna have jobs what are we talking
about here
just don't forget this has never been
done we've had flus before we've had
viruses before so this is something new
and this is why I say we have to I gave
it two weeks and you know I guess by
Monday or Tuesday it's about two weeks
and we'll assess at that time and we'll
give it some more time if we need a
little more time but we have to open
this country when they came to you and
had that conversation with you how long
did it take you to accept that new
reality
look I accept things I understand things
very quickly I mean I understood exactly
what they were saying but we can
socially distance ourselves and go to
work and you have to work a little bit
harder you can clean your hands five
times more than you used to you don't
have to shake hands anymore with people
that might be something good coming out
of this although I must tell you as a
politician it's a lot warmer when you
walk into a crowd you shake it a lot of
people's hands you love I'd agree with
you they love me and I love them you
know but but it is a little bit colder
but but you won't be shaking hands for
at least a while and and things will
happen but we have to put the country to
work look you're gonna lose a number of
people to the flu but you're gonna lose
more people by putting a country into a
massive recession or depression
you're gonna lose people you're gonna
have suicides by the thousands you're
gonna have all sorts of things happen
you're gonna have instability you can't
just come in and say let's close up the
United States of America the biggest the
most successful country in the world by
far you know when I came in when I was
elected and you knew this number China
was gonna overtake us in the year 2019
it wasn't even close we went way up and
they didn't we've done great they pay us
a fortune in tariffs and everything else
and yet we have a good relationship with
them we just signed a trade deal but
with the number one in the world by far
and now a few people walk into the Oval
Office say sir we have to close up the
country and the Saudis I said what do
you know that mr. president must have
been a very difficult thing to accept
one of the most difficult decisions I've
ever made
because I knew that when you do it
as soon as you
do it you're gonna drop I mean they're
talking about 20 or 25 points of GDP
nobody's ever heard of 25 points if we
went down a point that's a big deal now
all of a sudden you're basically turning
off the country I said this has never
been done before what are you talking
about but we understand it you have hot
spots but we've had hot spots before
we've had horrible flus I mean think of
it we averaged 36,000 people
death death I'm not talking about cases
I'm talking about death 36,000 deaths a
year people die 36 from the flu but
we've never closed down the country for
the flu so you say to yourself what is
this all about now how did you it's
never been how did you process that not
good I wasn't happy about it and I also
knew that I had to do it because look
with turkey I give this as an example in
Syria I said sign a deal with the Kurds
make peace they're the one he didn't
want to he said he's a man who loves
Turkey and I have a very good relation I
said sign a deal he didn't really want
to the Kurds didn't really want to and
it went on you know the so-called safe
zone the freeze recently a few months
ago I said sign a deal do me a favor
sign it they'll get it done they didn't
really want to all of a sudden they
start fighting fighting fighting
fighting and it was vicious and other
countries got involved now I say let's
sign a deal they said okay well sign a
deal we needed a period because I don't
think if I would have not done it we
would have been unbelievably criticized
for not doing it but it's never been
done before one more bill somehow the
word got out that this is the thing
we're supposed to be doing now we've had
some really bad epidemics and other
things I mean we're going this pandemic
but we've had bad epidemics I'm sure
they could have been called pandemics
but we never did a thing like this
before
but I had to do it it's been very
painful for our country and very
destabilizing for our country and we
have to go back to work much sooner than
people thought and people can go back to
work and they can also practice good
judgment one last question then we get
back to our viewers here - a month ago
the CDC had an initial test that failed
at that moment late February you said
it's perfect and it wasn't perfect so
what happened there in the early stages
was in late February said it's perfect
was my conversation with the head of the
Ukraine that's what I really said is
perfect okay that was another old
scandal nonsense a total you know
witch-hunt but this one is a much
different thing we had other
administration's not just the last one
they built up a platform they built up a
test but the test was no good it didn't
handle large numbers of people it was
okay for a very small group but not for
a large group so we had to break it down
did the CDC screw up or did you screw no
we did not screw at this and I don't
think CDC screwed up either they had a
test that would have worked for a small
group of people in other words for a
normal problem I don't think anybody
could have
in all fairness to CDC and this is a big
government agency and they're very good
people in there but nobody ever expected
a thing like this nobody would say that
millions and millions of people would
have been tested so what we did is we
broke that egg we broke that system and
we've created a new system that now
we're doing unbelievably big numbers and
it's set for the future should we ever
need it again I hope we don't need it
again thank you for your time we're
gonna bring the others in as well in a
moment thank you for being patient we
will get to you we have so many
questions not only from our network but
from millions of people all across the
country so your questions in a moment
here as we continue live in the Rose
Garden at the White House with the
president and his task force in
Washington
welcome back to our Fox News virtual
town hall with President Trump and his
coronavirus task force excited to
finally get to be able to talk
one-on-one with him now we got our tech
problems worked out I want to first ask
you mr. president about the idea of the
political division that's going on on
Capitol Hill you're talking about these
bills this phase one two and three of
the stimulus bill like they're gonna fix
so much with the economy and people are
literally fighting like cats I mean what
can you do to bring them together well I
think they're actually coming together
we had a bill that was done the other
night and then all of a sudden somebody
else injected herself in and all of that
we didn't have a we didn't have anything
that was even remotely signed a ball but
now I hear just from a few minutes ago
that they're doing well and it's for the
workers it's for the people of the
country and I hear they're doing pretty
well so we'll see how it comes out but
it should have been well it's like I
watched Governor Cuomo and he was very
nice we're building him hospitals were
building on medical centers and he was
complaining about we're doing probably
more definitely more fit than anybody
else and he was talking about the
ventilators but he should have ordered
the ventilators and he had a choice he
had a chance because right here I just
got this out that he refused to order
15,000 ventilators I'll show this to
bill but take a look at that bill what
does that say social distancing here
this says New York Governor Cuomo
rejected buying recommended 16,000
ventilators in 2015 for the pandemic for
a pandemic established death panels and
a lotteries instead so he had a chance
to buy in 2015 16,000 ventilators at a
very low price and he turned it down I'm
not blaming him or anything else but he
shouldn't be talking about us he's
supposed to be buying his own
ventilators we're gonna help but you
know if you think about ITIF you think
about Governor Cuomo wig building him
for hospitals we're building him for
medical centers we're working very very
hard for the people of New York we're
working along with him and then I
watched him on the show complaining and
yet 16,000 ventilators that he could
have had it a great price that he didn't
buy
I am yeah and I hear you going back and
forth and and Governor Cuomo has talked
in recent days that you regularly talk
and have a good relationship and so we
will follow the news as you're bringing
it to us there right there in the Rose
Garden I want to get to a viewer because
the people's voice is so huge right now
and always mr. president Joyce submitted
a question from Facebook about the
stimulus checks let's watch and I want
to get your reaction I am fortunate I
can continue to work I can telecommute
there are people who are losing jobs
they're losing an entire income for a
household and rather than receive a
check I would just like to pay it
forward and have the government passed
mine one to someone else
Wow is that great well you obviously
come from West Virginia and I love that
state and thank you very much Joyce I'll
tell you what that's great I wish we had
more people like Joyce I'll tell you but
you know it's going to be a substantial
amount of money around $3,000 for a
family of four and assuming it all gets
done assuming we can get the Democrats
to sign it but it'll be great but Joyce
I think that's such a nice gesture
really I appreciate it thank you well
and you just said right when you and I
began talking a few minutes ago that you
know almost in breaking news fashion it
looks like the juggernaut might be
moving on Capitol Hill to try to push
toward that stimulus bill so we'll be
watching for that you know mr. president
I'm watching the Dow as you have been
talking and formerly the vice president
it's up by more than 1500 points what do
you watch for each day I mean are you
keeping your eye on that is it is it
companies calling you small and large
like what what is your barometer that
okay things were in trouble or things
are doing better well I think the Dow
was helped by the fact that they you
know there were theories that we're
going to stay out for four or five
months and you can't do that as I
couldn't you destroy our country if you
did a thing like that and we're going to
be opening relatively soon and we are
our time comes up and Monday or Tuesday
our you know the allotted two weeks but
we'll stay a little bit longer than that
but we want to get open very soon I
think that was
big reason it's gone up I also think
that the fact that the Senate and the
house I've we seem to be getting along
as much as you can get along we seem to
be getting along now on a on a bill I I
think that maybe had even less of an
impact than the fact that we're opening
up this incredible country because we
have to do that
I'd love to have it open by Easter okay
I would love to have it open by Easter I
will I will tell you that right now I
would love to have that it's such an
important day for other reasons but I'll
make it an important day for this too I
would love to have the country opened up
and they're just raring to go by Easter
that's April 12th so we will watch and
see what happens I'm gonna toss it back
to my cohort bill thank you Harris that
would be a great American resurrection
two and a half Plus weeks from this dr.
Burks a series of questions on the
medical front here I want to go to
Allison from Indiana appropriately so
mr. vice president who has a question by
way of facebook about possible mutation
watch my question is this if you were to
get the corona virus can it mutate and
can you get it again mm-hmm dr. Burks so
that's a great question and a very smart
question because it's an RNA virus it
can mutate and it constantly mutates but
what has been pretty good about the
corona viruses in general is they keep
their structural pieces very similar
what do I mean by that there's certain
the outer coat the envelope and the
inside part of the virus has stayed very
constant it's even very similar to SARS
which we haven't seen since 2003 and so
we what has been picked for sites both
for the vaccine and for monoclonal
antibodies are very much those constant
sites and we believe that anybody who
becomes positive and makes effective
antibody because there are some people
who can't make as good of antibody as
others but if you make effective
antibody you shouldn't get reinfected
the way it was described to me and
corrects the medical positioning of this
question but the virus is trying to
figure out a way to survive and that's
where it moves around and new
dates now in Singapore there was a
headline earlier today suggesting a
possible second wave in that island
nation how do you how do you gauge that
this very in Singapore they took the
president's guidelines and they executed
them very early because they could see
China next door and so they saw those
and they implemented those guidelines so
very few people became infected in
Singapore because so few people have
been infected you don't have what they
call herd immunity and so until we get
through this current pandemic this if it
has seasonality which we hope and
believe it could if it gets through this
current season it will be in everybody's
best interest to do as the president has
recommended our work on vaccines our
work on additional therapeutics and
really getting to both pre and post
prophylaxis so that the healthcare
providers can get get a shot potentially
that will protect them we would call it
pre exposure prophylaxis all of those
things are being worked on to prepare us
for the next season we're so we're
focused today on what we need today and
to get through this current epidemic and
then we're also getting prepared in case
it comes back in the fall or in case it
comes back in the fall of 2021 when we'd
have it back I'm gonna bring in the
Surgeon General in this and to both of
you I've been listening to you very
carefully for weeks now and what you've
said is we want to be the model of South
Korea well South Korea has flattened the
curve to borrow a phrase and their death
rate is about 1.2 percent this morning
here in the US our death rate was right
around that same mark 1.3 percent - the
Surgeon General what does that tell you
or how much do you consider the death
rate here at home when we try and make
decisions for ourselves well thank you
for that bill I think there are a couple
of important things for the American
people to remember the first one is that
when you look at the data here in the
United States of all the people who
we've tested so far only about 90
percent of those well 90 percent of
those folks do not have the coronavirus
they test negative so most people even
when they have cold and flu symptoms do
not have coronavirus number one
number two ninety-eight ninety-nine
percent of people are recovering so
people need to understand yes some
people will get coronavirus in many
communities across America but that most
of them will recover that that's very
important for people to understand and
beyond that we're trying to help people
understand the importance of stopping
the spread and the president when he
nine days ago listened to his health his
health providers his health his health
consultants he said what do we need to
do right now and we said we need to lean
into this next two weeks to stop the
spread and then we need to re reassess
and one thing I can tell you for certain
is that I've been on the task force for
three weeks and the president listens to
Tony Falchi he listens to dr. Burks he
listens one eye or dr. Carson or dr.
Hahn or dr. Redfield speak up and he
also listens to the governor's and so we
will assess at the end of the 14 days
and we'll figure out the most
appropriate thing to do and based on my
experience in the task force so far the
president will make an appropriate
decision based on all the data thank you
for that answer is everything cool with
you and dr. Falchi he was not there he
wasn't there last night for the briefing
he's not here today as he has other your
relationships good I think it's been
very good you would have heard about it
if it wasn't I mean every time he does
he's not in a meeting and sometimes
other people do they said why isn't dr.
Brooks at a meeting is there a problem
and I said Debra could you please come
to the meeting do you mind because no
they they you know I respect all of
these people these are great people and
Debra is extraordinary and Tony's
extraordinary I get along with all of
them but if there's you know they have
other things to do and yesterday we
weren't really talking about what he's
an expert on we were talking about other
things a lot of other things and you
know they I don't think they should be
at every show he's got you're good
that's the point yeah we're fine dr.
Burks early on you said it with the
massive amount of testing in South Korea
96% to the surgeon general's what 96
percent came back negative I think
that's an important point to convey
again to the American people Noah from
Maryland has a question now his
question is about health care workers on
the front lines of this pandemic now my
mother is a nurse she works in the
health care field what do you and your
team plan to do to help health care
workers that are putting themselves at
risk every single day as a result of the
coronavirus excellent question dr. Burks
you wanna yeah that's I love that
question because my mother's a nurse
she's 91 now so she's not practicing but
I think we have to remember in majority
of hospitals in the majority of places
it is the nurse that are the frontlines
they're the ones working every moment
with the patients to ensure that they do
well they're the ones at the bedside
they're the ones providing comfort
they're the ones providing the medical
interventions and they are our first
priority it is why we've worked so hard
to get the protective personal
protective equipment out there but I
think what we didn't often talk about is
we're really with the changing
guidelines for testing that is going to
free up all of that personal protective
devices that were being utilized for
testing back into the hospitals and the
clinics for our nurses and doctors and
that's going to make millions of more
masks and PPE as we call it available to
the hospital workers who need it the
most because now people can self test
and bill can I jump in on that really
quickly I want people to know that I'm a
still practicing anesthesiologist at
Walter Reed the vice president and I we
first met during Ebola and I went into
the hospital I put on PPE I know how
scary it is even when you have the
proper equipment to deal with an
infectious disease and I'm getting text
phone calls messages from people all
across the country and I want health
care workers of America to know we are
fighting for you each and every day to
make sure you get what you need from the
stockpile to make sure you get what you
need from manufacturers across America
to make sure you're getting decreased
demand which is why we put out our new
guidelines on elective surgeries because
it's not just about increasing the
supply we aren't going to supply our way
out of this problem
as important as supply is we need to
also lower demand by decreasing
unnecessary
usage of PPE and a game changer that
just came out just this week was the new
FDA self swabs and the vice president
and the president have talked about that
that will utilize less PPE so we're
working on making sure supply gets where
it needs to and FEMA is doing a great
job without lowering demand how can
someone watching this right now acquire
a self-test well right now the FDA is
making that more available we've seen
testing increase in real numbers when
you look at last week from Monday to
Friday the amount of testing increased
tenfold so we're seeing testing increase
that the concern is it's actually using
up more PPE which is why we want to
prioritize testing for the people who
are most in need the health care workers
and the people who are vulnerable and
why we're pushing the FDA has lowered
barriers like none other to make sure we
can get these new testing modalities
available that use less PPE and do more
tests thank you for that back to Harris
now with another question Harris all
right actually you know what I want to
stay on this home testing kit topic for
just a second with dr. Burks you know
the home tests whose is there a place
where people check a box and say I'm
positive or not how are you going to
keep up with people who test themselves
and you need that information dr. Burks
to know where the clusters are in the
country that's part of why you would do
it great so it's not a home test it's a
self test so what do I mean by that I
mean the individual can drive up receive
the items because again we still want to
just test people with fever and symptoms
that are really need to be tested they
can self swab the front of their nose
put it in the container then the person
can collect it with gloves gloves alone
with the biohazard bag and get it in I
just want to speak to the Americans for
just a second though we have to ensure
that we still are testing even though
probably by today we will have done more
tests than South Korea did in eight
weeks in the last eight days in the last
eight days we've done more testing than
South Korea but we did that because we
transform the testing process as the
president spoke to but we don't want
people who are just worried to go get
tested if you don't have a persistent
fever if you don't have a coffee if
you're not in the risk group if you're
not a nurse or doctor we
really want the testing and the
drive-through testing and the testing
that is provided in the cities to be
very much still focused on the people
who need it because there's only so much
even those high throughput machines are
doing they're doing about 50 60 70
thousand tests a day now they could get
potentially to 150,000 a day but we want
to make sure we're testing in the areas
that really have the problems and go
right ahead
yeah thanks Harris you know American
people are asking all the time the
president I hear it all the time and see
it it's what what can they do to make a
difference and in addition to the 15
days to slow the spread the American
people could take dr. Burke's advice
it's that old proverb that it's not the
healthy who need a doctor but the sick
and one of the ways that you can help is
by recognizing we want to focus testing
on people that have symptoms although
according to the tests now as the
Surgeon General said 90% of the people
that have been tested for the corona
virus don't have it okay that that
number we tested more than 320,000
people and and that's an encouraging
number I would expect but for any
American out there that just may be
concerned but not be symptomatic one of
the ways you can make sure the testings
available for people that have symptoms
and just as importantly for our health
care workers that we want to make sure
have all the protective equipment that
they need you can you can recognize that
if you don't have symptoms don't do a
test Harris one thing that Phil Harris
one thing I might add that to me is so
important again we took something that
was broken and we made it the model and
I didn't even know I just heard the
number for the first time from Deborah
that in a short period of time we've
done more testing than South Korea now
you're not going to read that in the
newspapers because they don't like to
write things like that but I'd love you
to say that one more time because that
that's a big number we've done more than
South Korea in a short period of time
we're doing more now than South Korea by
Allah
what was that number so we're believing
that they're probably around two
thousand nine twenty nine hundred two
thousand twenty-nine thousand three
hundred ninety thousand three hundred
and now we're way over three hundred
thousand but we read that over the last
seven to eight days we have to do more
we understand that over eight weeks
we're going up proportionally we're
going up very very rapidly every day
what was our negative test rate at the
moment it's great is it 90 percenter is
it higher so I really am glad you asked
because this gets into where is the
virus now and where is it expanding and
so across the country our test rates are
still way under 10 percent except for
one place New York City Metro New York
New Jersey close to New York City those
rates are coming in in the 28 percent
range right now New York the case attack
rate what we're talking about the number
of people who are getting infected is
four to five times any other place in
the country is that density popular I
think part of it is density part of is
the spread that may have happened on
metal surfaces like in the subway and
people that were in the subway part of
it may be a large number of people came
back after Christmas from Asia that
didn't get caught up in the closure you
blame the governor for that and part of
it could be the Europeans who have come
back subsequently and there's I mean
obviously it's a big area of world trade
and global transit so I think the virus
probably was quietly expanding because
until it gets into an older population
you don't really see it in the same
thank you for that and we'll get to all
of you again in a moment here gonna get
a quick break here more of your
questions from across America here at
the White House in the Rose Garden
[Music]
welcome back to our Fox News virtual
town hall with President Trump and
members of his task force we are in the
Rose Garden here at the White House and
it's a real honor to be sitting here
with you all and I hope together we can
kill the virus and give a lot of people
hope about getting back to their regular
lives true
you said something 20 minutes ago that
I'm sure a lot of people were pretty
keen on you you said that we would I'm
paraphrasing now you would like to be
back to normal by Easter Sunday yes
that's 19 days from now okay is that
true is that possible or is it possible
why isn't it I mean we've never closed
the country before and we've had some
pretty bad flus and we've had some
pretty bad viruses and I think it's
absolutely possible now people are going
to have to practice all of the social
distancing and don't shake hands and
wash your hands and all of the things
that we're doing now but we have to get
our country back to work our country
wants to be back at work that was not a
controversial thing I said the other day
our country wants to go back to work and
and again the cure it's it's like this
cures is worse than the problem again
people many people in my opinion more
people are going to die if we allow this
to continue we have to go back to work
our people want to go back to work what
you have said consistently as the first
order of business is to kill the virus
so so when you look at the data from
around the world across our country how
do you determine that 19 days from now
it might be safe because there are
millions of people watching this it may
have their family fortune on the line
well they have their family fortune on
the line the other way too they're going
to lose their jobs maybe never to get
them back they're gonna lose their
businesses never to get them back we
want to start up as soon as we can
because we're gonna have a very quick
comeback if we do that if we delay this
thing out you're gonna lose more people
than you're losing with the with the
situation as we know it so I think it's
very important for our country to go
back and I've had many many people you
know when you said it was a little bit
controversial not to most people most
people think I'm right about it now
whether we're locked in a room or
whether we're in our office and
practicing all of the things that we're
supposed to be
practicing staying away from each other
you know it cetera it's not shaking
hands washing your hands all the time
but our country has to get back to work
otherwise otherwise it's going to be
very hard to start it up again we can't
lose the advantage that we have what
we're trying to figure out in this whole
scenario here is how deadly the virus is
and so far it is highly contagious but
not very deadly we can agree on that
based on the data correct yes yeah so
when you take the answer of Easter
Sunday do you see that as realistic do
you see that as possible
so my job and I think what's really
important is a lot of what we've done is
we've tackled this epidemic the way
people said we should have tackled flu
in 1918 and they compared Saint Louis
who took this kind of approach to
Philadelphia what we're trying to do now
is use 21st century solutions and trying
to get data down to the most granular
level so we understand what's happening
at the area of the spread so even today
there are counties throughout the United
States that don't have their first case
so our job is to make sure they never
have their first case and ensure that
our efforts are focused on where the
virus is expanding that can be done
today because we have that level of
granularity so that's what the president
has asked us to put together to use
these two weeks to get all the data from
around the country and all the data from
around the globe and really understand
what's working and it's really important
that the Americans know I know the vice
president covered this very clearly in
the first hour but every American needs
to continue the president's guidelines
for these next these next six days or
seven days we have to have them
following those guidelines if the
Surgeon General shaking his head in
agreement
excuse me just one second you can't
compare this to 1918 we're close to a
hundred million people died that was a
flu which little different but that was
a flu where if you got it you had a
50-50 chance are very close of dying
I think we're substantially under 1%
because the people that get better are
not reporting so we only know people
that go to doctors who go to hospitals
that we're taking that
we're still a little bit above 1% when
you add all of the people the millions
of people that have it that get better
we're substantially less than 1% and
when they came to my office don't forget
they were saying 3% 4% 5% this is a very
big difference no we have to put a
country back to work we have a few
minutes left and I want to bring in our
panel of experts - dr. Mehmet Oz is with
us dr. mark Siegel and dr. Nicole
sapphire when we give you guys around 2
questions quickly here when dr. Oz why
don't we start with dr. Siegel this time
around go ahead mark mr. president with
the deaths going over 600 today I want
to say that fear the fear that's coming
out of this disturbs me the most and
fear divides you need unification and
unified leadership to fight the fear so
I was really encouraged to see you're
reaching out to governor's Governor
Cuomo governor Newsom making making
liaisons that weren't there before do
you think that that kind of movement
where you're the leader and other people
work with you will help us to isolate
the virus and the epicenters where they
are to separate out those epicenters to
test the people in those centers and to
thereby squash the virus I do I think
dr. it's a very good thing and governor
Newsom and I have been getting along
really great we're sending the ship the
great hospital ship as you know and we
are doing very well with I think almost
all of the governor's for the most part
it really has become something it's it's
we're dealing almost every day we're
speaking to each other whether it's
conference calls usually we'll have 50
governors of the call at the same time
no I think we're doing very well but you
know it's a two-way street they have to
treat us well also they can't say oh gee
we should get this we should get that
we're doing a great job like in New York
where we're building as I said for
hospitals for minute we're literally
building hospitals and medical centers
and then I hear that you know there's a
problem with ventilators well we sent
them ventilators and they could have had
15 or 16 thousand all they had to do is
order him two years ago but they decided
not to do it they can't blame us for
that dr. oz is up next go ahead doctor
president Trump a good surgeon knows
after the surgery when his patient gave
me this charge and these 15 days are
like a big
operation on America what a great
surgeon knows when there's a
complication after discharge so if we
can meet the goal of fixing America and
getting it back on his feet by Easter I
love to know exactly how you know that
is safe from medical perspective what's
going to indicate that we might have to
pull back a tiny bit in case we have a
relapse well I think doctor a thing like
that could happen but I really believe
that we could do much of what we're
doing and we could do it from a work
environment instead of a an environment
where everybody's locked up and
everybody is saying oh the business is
gone the business is gone and
everybody's suffering depression you
know better than anybody about
depression I've watched where you talk
about depression and that causes death
and it causes a lot of problems and you
know these are people they want to save
their business they don't want to be
locked up in some room or some apartment
or house and in the meantime their
restaurants closed their businesses
closed they want to be saving their
business and I believe very strongly
you're gonna lose far more people by
going that way than you are if we kept
this thing going I could keep them out I
mean I'm sure that we have doctors that
would say let's keep it closed for two
years okay let's close it up for two
years now we got to get it open or
people want it open and that's the way
this country was built dr. Nicole
Sapphire now doctor go ahead with your
question thank you and president Trump I
do believe as a nation that we are
beholden to you for your decisive swish
swift action in the beginning with the
travel ban I do think that we would have
been in a much different worse situation
had that not happened however we still
did have a lag in the testing which of
course did not have anything to do with
you but my question is for dr. Burks and
the task force as we still see across
the nation that some people are not able
to get tests I have colleagues that
still can't test some of their patients
is there a plan to fast-track or even
parallel track wrap it Eliza their
logical testing to try and get this out
there so that we can mobilize it more
PPE and more hospital beds by doing more
testing and being able to isolate those
people quickly yeah that's a very good
question so right now the tests that we
have are all based on the RNA of the
virus and so we're utilizing the
platforms and
goodness were utilizing the platforms
that were developed really to work and
support hiv-positive clients so this is
their their machines that have been used
to detect their viral load for the last
more than a decade in the United States
those machines right now are being
utilized for this test in a
high-throughput way we've asked
developers to work on a point-of-care
fingerprint test that could be used for
antibody and antigen but the antibody
test will only tell you if you have been
infected even if we can get IgM it will
be part of the early and probably
recovery phase and then we're working
with companies to work on getting RNA
tests at our point of care so these are
really critical tests that people are
working on right now but in the meantime
we're using what we have today to ensure
that we can get more testing done and I
just wanted to say I want to thank the
American people and physicians who have
let us prioritize remember we didn't
have this platform until eight days ago
we've done all of these diagnoses for
inpatients primarily so that they can
get on the appropriate therapy and we
prioritize our testing to hospital
patients we will over the next few weeks
be able to make more tests available to
the actual American public with symptoms
and to the doctor's offices as you've
requested and Nicole it's important to
remember we've done more tests in eight
days then South Korea is done in eight
weeks and our tests are better they're
highly sophisticated and frankly I took
one it's not the most pleasant thing in
the world I will tell you that we're
gonna have a much simpler test very soon
but we have a really good test and we've
done more in eight days nobody know that
I just heard this number a few minutes
ago I learned it from being on your show
actually I think the way you described
it was up the nasal passage and right
now you're right at the I do all of you
stand by we've got a few more moments
left here but as our virtual Town Hall
continues to all the doctors and the
Coase a fireman that AHS and Mark Siegel
we very much rely on you in a day to day
basis so thank you for being a part of
this today
quick commercial break back to the Rose
Garden in a moment as our town hall
continues
back here in the Rose Garden the White
House I'm bill hemmer along with my
colleague harris faulkner have about 90
seconds left and just with the panel
here the president the vice president
dr. Burks and the Surgeon General thank
you again for your time I see this as a
public service but also as a way to try
and figure out what the facts are and
that's that's the reason we came here
but you were just saying again mr. vice
president during the commercial the way
you can achieve your objective is how
well the president made it clear
yesterday that we we want to open up the
country as soon as we can but the key is
the more Americans and tens of millions
are bill more Americans have put into
practice the president's coronavirus
guidelines office because it's hard to
see if the sooner we'll be able to open
up what does it wash your hands if
you're sick stay home personal hygiene
it's it's if you if you're sick stay
home if someone in your house has the
virus stay home but it's also avoiding
groups of more than ten avoiding
unnecessary travel don't eat in
restaurants during this period of time
use the drive-through these are all the
principles that every American can do
now there are going to be Americans that
that have different guidance from their
state and local officials that are more
stringent we defer to that we respect
that but the more Americans who do this
the sooner that will be able as the
president said to get back to we have to
be a patient nation if you're gonna ask
them to do that as you well know mr.
president thank you for your time and
I'll see a bit later on Bill Hemmer
reports at 3 o'clock Eastern Time and
did mr. vice president Mike Pence thank
you dr. Burks terrific work in the
Surgeon General thank you for sharing
your knowledge with us today that is it
from here at the White House and Harris
I will see you back in New York very
soon I hope the last two hours held some
value for a lot of our viewers across
the country and around the world Harris